hasbro has just sent us the world's
first exclusive from the legend series
marvel studios dr strange i have
agamotto in retail packaging let's unbox
this bad boy let's find out if this is
worth your money let's check it out
[Music]
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
head shots with logitech g pro x super
light mouse the lightweight wireless
mouse combines excellent performance
with classy no frills look designed with
pros and engineered to win it offers
crisp and responsive clicks the smooth
operator even allows you to swap out the
magnetic dongle storage compartment for
greater gliding ease check out all of
its other features over at logitechg.com
let's unbox this thing first off before
we get into that let's move around the
box for 14 plus and older so for you
kids out there that are 13 and below
hasbro doesn't think you're worthy of
this you're going to have to be a little
bit older
moving around the box we're going to see
does come with a beautiful stand and you
do see it also has this lanyard as well
this sort of leather type lanyard that
looks you know very ancient like
doctor what doctor strange wears because
of course he is in spiderman no way home
and i guess they're tapping in on that
as well moving on to the back of this
we're going to see some of the features
of this eyeball gamoto it does uh the
time stone does come out of it we'll see
how that works in just a bit and it also
opens up
let's open up this bad boy
all right
we've got our safety papers we've got an
instruction manual to tell us how to put
the batteries inside the eye of agamotto
if you thought i'd run on the time stone
alone you are wrong
it does take it looks like double a
batteries
two double a batteries oh no sorry two
aaa batteries mind you two aaa batteries
because it's a little bit smaller so
there you go on that and uh also walk
you through on how to uh do certain
things
very cool
as you can see it's green and white to
kind of you know tie into the time stone
colors
hasbro thinks of everything don't they
oh it shows you how it opens it up and
it lights up in the stand as well
i'm excited to try this out
i'm hoping this is going to be a really
well-built product and something that we
definitely want to keep on our shelves
here i mean it's only coming around 50
us dollars and around 100 singapore
dollars they're about so it's not going
to be probably the best of the best in
build quality but i bet you it's gonna
surprise me at least i hope so okay
moving to the stand
it's lightweight
very lightweight
wow
it's quite hollow
nonetheless
it's got just good designer elements
around this so it looks really good the
paintwork is very nice
but this doesn't have a lot of weight to
it so i guess the eye of agamotto will
put that weight on it once you set it
down but you can see the attention to
detail that hasbro has put around this
with this sort of
aged sort of brass or a metal
texture to it a lot of the motif that we
see in
doctor strange
then we're going to move on to this
other part here
by the way
nothing fancy on the packaging guys just
brown boxing but of course always save
the packaging with any of these items
they are collector items so you never
know if you want to sell it one day it's
always with more when you have the
packaging
here is the stand
looks like uh yeah about the same build
quality as this does fit in like that it
looks like
let's find out how this goes in
i thought it was like low-key
very low-key s because of the green and
the the grow the gold
horns loki
right there or which loki
hopefully not sylvia
[Music]
i'm not a bad
okay moving on
ah the eye of agomoto is here
not wrapped up in anything mind you it's
just
here
there he goes oops
and there went the time stone hold on a
second look how that time stone comes
man it comes like a piece of candy yo if
parents the parents see it right now yo
i tell you
i tell you that's why they say 14 and
above man because some kids go mommy i
got candy inside then off to the
hospital they go
i'm looking at the lanyard real quick
here now this is actually quite nice
it's uh it feels like it's a little bit
like a leather material to this with
also some beautiful uh cotton threading
here so it's kind of a combination of
both this looks really nice i'm gonna be
honest with you and it looks like this
comes apart as well
let me see here
yes it does so that comes apart so you
can
clasp it on the back but since it's
already a pretty large lanyard you don't
really need to do that but it
does add an element to it um i have to
say i really like the lanyard on it
really good detail the i have agamotto
definitely has more weight than the
stand a place to put the time zone
inside
there's three gold prongs there so i
guess it uh
you put it inside and it automatically
lights it up
um it is plastic if you think it's metal
it is not it's a composite plastic
pretty i would say pretty solid in terms
of its feel the design around it the
elements look really good uh the motif
it's very detailed again it's got that
brushed sort of aged metal to it i mean
hats off to hasbro for that we have a
button here which i guess
does something we'll find out because
and we've got a butt on the back as well
two buttons let's remove the time stone
i would have thought the time song would
have come in at least clear plastic this
is kind of this is comical you match
pin to pin
put inside
sticks in
it doesn't close hold on
oh
you have to turn it
ah
there huh
what was that
oh okay okay okay okay okay okay i got
it gotta get it
if you turn it turn it turn it turn and
turn it
you turn it and it locks in like that
right
and then
it farts
then you gotta press and hold no i am i
think it's tired maybe it needs
batteries okay batteries are inside the
eye of agamotto now and
let's
try it out
oh
i see the light on the lens i wow
now we're talking
that's pretty badass look at that look
at that but to close it
like a lock
i gotta wear this thing man i gotta wear
it i could be like doctor strange do you
know the doctor strange rules yeah it's
like it's like it's like that it's like
that and then you go you go
you see there's no motion sensors on
this
so i have to go
that's what i have to do to open it up
okay fingers this way
it's the eye now i move it this way
and now it opens
[Music]
wow
see that's what i'm talking about
thanks gerald
so as you can tell i'm not a man of the
mystic arts but there is a button on the
back of this yet that we have not
pressed okay
let's check this out push i don't know
what this does
[Applause]
time stone comes out oh man it's like a
rocket
launcher looks like it ran out of time
oh
sorry
i mean i know it's supposed to float out
like in you know in the movie it floats
out but the nice thing is the light
stays lit up that's quite cool right see
it's like slick charge heads up on this
this is a bright time stone we're going
to turn the lights off and you're going
to open up the eye of agamotto
ready ready gerald yeah all right let's
do it starting and now the ivago moto
opens up
it look good does it look good xeno what
do you think it looks good
right it's badass right brandon
it glows good right
this looks really good in the dark can
you use it as a flashlight good idea
zack a good idea good idea
can you see me yeah yeah man this is
good right
hey maybe i lost something in my house
the power is out and i'll use the eye of
agamotto to help me find it that's not
how night vision works man
hey man when you when the lights are out
of your house you lose power you got to
use what you got so the eye of agamotto
cool all right let's put the lights back
on
all right so now we're going to put the
i bogamoto on here on the stand so it
sits in like that this will look really
cool on a bookshelf or let's say in your
collector's case like we have back here
or display case as a whole this looks
really good but we're going to show you
something really cool we got in the geek
culture studios this is from disney this
is something you can't buy right this is
from 2016.
this is
you could say the real ibagamoto in a
way because this is metal
now this stone doesn't come out
obviously a different color than that
one this is a very exclusive collector's
piece we're not selling it um but yeah
from disney themselves how cool is that
final thoughts on this bad boy the eye
of august moto of course it is plastic
as well it's 50 us dollars so it's not
going to be metal like this i would have
it would have been nice if
hasbro would have made a collector's
version even if you charge more to be
somewhat similar to this quality i think
that would have been a great deal the
sound
is a little bit odd i'm gonna be honest
it sounds a bit like it's farting
it does you know it could have been
smoother better but it is what it is
anyway
those are my thoughts on
the eye of agamotto from hasbro the
legend series let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below are you
looking to pick this up 50 bucks it's
not gonna break the bank
or
would you hold out for something a
little bit more robust even if it's more
expensive i would love to hear from you
guys anyway with that stay safe take
care follow us on facebook subscribe to
us on youtube like this video and i'll
chat you in the next one take care
you could put this here
and then
i would get this for my display case for
sure that is wicked
actually it looks yeah right for 50
bucks i would get this for my display
case i mean literally this this is cool
yeah
there we go
[Music]
you